we're talking about weather this morning
because three-quarters of the country is
waking up to below freezing temperatures
as a second winter storm this week makes
its way east the National Weather
Service forecasts temperatures more than
20 degrees below normal across the
Northeast today Oh so cold the low is in
Rutland Vermont and it hit a negative 17
degrees Pittsburg bottomed out at just
two degrees that's as a death toll from
last weekend storm climbs to at least
seven now a system in the West is
dumping snow across parts of Utah and is
expected to move into the Midwest and
there on the east DeMarco Morgan is in
Groton Connecticut with the effects of
the extreme cold DeMarco boy we feel for
you today good morning to you O gala
brother is cold out here it is extremely
cold and dangerously cold actually
Monday was the coldest day here in
Connecticut so far for this here and if
you take a look at this boardwalk here
at the Eastern Point Beach you can see
it's completely frozen and it's the ice
and the chill that's making this weekend
storm very dangerous for many people
across the Northeast there's really no
getting around it the snow and ice had
to be cleared out and upstate New York
even those who were doing it advised
others against needlessly braving the
elements a lot of people should stay
inside keep warm don't go out unless you
have to fighting fires is it any easier
in these conditions crews in New York
City rotated shifts every 20 minutes to
keep warm as they put out a three alarm
fire the after map shows the building
encased in ice in Indianapolis fire
teams used flames to thaw icy hydrants
we have to attack it with some heat to
get it unthought quickly and so that can
take a couple extra minutes and we know
that fire doubles in size every minute
the dangerously low temps followed snow
that crude too deadly a 12 y/o girl
outside Chicago was killed what a snow
fort she built collapsed on top of her
and at least three people died from
shoveling in upstate New York
seven-year-old frank Tomasi was found on
his front steps Monday morning he
suffered a heart attack Sunday night
while trying to clear his property
there's a lot of bearing down and upper
body work that actually increases your
blood pressure as
you scoop and shovel that snow and get
your arms raised off so if you do plan
on coming out here be careful extremely
careful even with the proper boot zone
this here is a thick sheet of ice so
it's extremely dangerous but there's
some good news it's expected to warm up
by Wednesday actually it will be in the
40s so that's good news for this area
but when the ice starts to melt it could
also lead to flooding and there's a
chance of snow for this weekend we'll
send things back to you tomorrow I'm
glad you put your hood back I didn't
know if that was you underneath there it
looks so warm well you're a trooper
thank you